you may have heard there was a threat
at capitol hill
there was a bomb threat on capitol hill
there was a video a live stream from
the person who made the threat take a
listen
they sitting in cars all over this place
around here because you thought the
south wasn't coming
will joe biden the south come
the roads are blocked
and i'm waiting on your phone call
it's your call
you got an option
you can shoot me and kill me right here
and blow up two and a half city blocks
and let all the patrons out in the
country know
because i ain't here to blow nobody up
i ain't here to hurt nobody
if i was i wouldn't have told them to
tell people to leave
i would have gunned this [ __ ]
wrote it right up in your front door
[Music]
but i'm here for a reason joe biden
[Music]
i'm here for a reason
i'm here for the american people
thankfully this guy was taken into
custody was disarmed nobody got hurt it
wasn't
there was no horrible consequence of
this most interesting though is not what
he did or what the cops did it's that a
lot of people don't believe that any of
this is real
so the big trending news all of
yesterday is the capital bomb threat
even as afghanistan is in the news major
probably the worst debacle
so far of the biden administration i
guess
compared to the immigration problem it's
they're neck and neck one is the major
domestic debacle one is a major foreign
debacle
but
a really bad week for joe biden and then
this is in the news that this
may be right winger i mean he doesn't
like joe biden he's from the south
there's a chance he's a right winger
that he's there trying to blow up the
capital
so
the cops disarm him
they take him into custody we haven't
heard very much since
to me what's much more interesting
is if you look in the comments section
on people on the video on articles about
the video
it's a lot of people saying yeah this
looks staged this looks fake
this isn't real
this is an op
this is just they're trying to pull
another one over on us
now
i'm not i'm not saying that's the case
i think he's just a guy who was a kook
and now he's been taken into custody
but i understand why people
don't think this is real
they don't think it's real for the
political reason that our leaders lie to
us and they cheat and they rig things
and they try to pull a fast one and our
administrative state the bureaucracy the
deep state the surveillance state has
gotten completely out of control and we
know that not only do they perform
clandestine activities on americans but
they lie about it too i mean we know
this from the fact that the the
surveillance state spied on donald trump
at the behest of barack obama during the
2016 election we know that they
continually tried to subvert his
presidency we know that they spy on
americans they were spying on tucker
carlson for goodness sakes so we know
these sorts of things happen
uh
so that would be one that'd be the
political reason we just don't trust
these guys
but there's the technological reason too
it all seems
like a movie i mean it literally is a
movie the only reason anyone knows about
this is because this guy is live
streaming it from his truck and we're
all inside his truck with him
and we know that technology can be very
deceiving with the advent of deep fakes
with the advent of
just streaming technology generally
these these sorts of things can be
produced and cultivated and curated
for our consumption for a particular
end of communications we don't
this is much deeper than just we don't
like our government and we don't trust
them i mean that's a big problem too
but it's a it's a technological
revolution that's taken place that is
that is challenging our belief in
reality itself
we just don't i i can no longer believe
my lying eyes
in a world with the ability to
manipulate media and push it out to
millions and millions and millions of
people as we have
we can no longer just believe the things
that we see even with our it used to be
don't believe everything you see in in
newspapers now it's don't believe
everything you see
on video or here or perhaps even with
your own eyes
glad you like that clip the full episode
is called the end of the world as we
know it you can get it here on youtube
so subscribe leave a comment you know
get that going but
what i would recommend
go to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your
podcasts search for the michael knowles
show subscribe
thank you thank you for doing that leave
a five star review we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you